oh my man Paul got it hey yeah sure um
who's dishing this it's mine it's just
one please don't trip
mo get the dish that's nasty hey man I
thought you'd be more excited you know
it's been a long time since you bro come
on man you kind of move on I'm serious
what if I don't want to do you let her
win mo get the dish don't let her win
Paul don't let her win but she's all I
need in this life of sin oh please not
be right there that lyric only applies
if she were your girlfriend she's not
even girlfriend she cheated exactly and
I don't think that sing rhymes with
conniving [ __ ] oh hey get your dish
Paul listen forget about your ex okay
what was Samantha she's a really nice
girl tip dish dish a no goddamn dish
what a little finger thing ah you guys
banging then please fill out one tune
you want another one
yeah I'm toast up girl got the token
it'll guy or a star birthday
starboard sky Machoke Alaska hey so
what's your favorite game Samantha any
other TV game there's a basketball game
over there you're pretty good at that
and amazing a little killer I don't know
I'll beat you Kobe okay sorry alright
you want shoot another one
oh my gosh it's just one dish right it's
sitting the same
oh that's how it starts just one oh we
only lost by one state's vote
oh we're just splitting one atom oh it's
just one vote off the African shoreline
comparison awesome George 720p hello
dude I am freaking out
Christina just called me does she want
to get back together I don't know what
to say nothing you say nothing wouldn't
be weird if I'm just quiet on the other
side of the phone oh she called you by
accident man under no circumstances do
you return that call but what nope all
right all right
okay so where'd you guys end up going
yeah Cade you know did your mom's drop
you off touch each other you ready to
finally talk about that next step of
Sarah Marcus it's not a dish from Beauty
and the Beast it's not gonna get up to
walk away oh really because other things
of mine have gotten up in this house and
walked away apparently my ipod my Maya
CD she's got the best of me another one
of my favorite nice play hockey
I don't know if we should be playing Oh
hello Christina hey what's up man
yeah yeah the arcade over now the other
one
yeah cool all right bye hey are you okay
we were like acting kind of weird in
there mm-hm well I had a really great
time yeah yeah hey you need a ride home
alright now I'm good I got my board I'll
skate home okay well I guess we'll hang
out again soon oh yeah yeah thanks
by
can you give me one second hello hey you
needed me no you called me what you
called me earlier I was just returning
it
hey um Paul I have to go bays about to
perform and sorry it was probably a
butt-dial
TJ yourself okay yeah you too if you
just practice putting your dishes away
then we wouldn't have a problem you
don't have any problems oh well oh do
you have a problem with this no just one
day just one dish okay you guys are not
seeing the bigger picture here right
that monk is going to get harder and
harder then you have to let it soak then
you have to buy extra shrimp dish soap
then you have to go to therapy all right
all because you can get rid of something
you could have gotten rid of a very long
time ago oh good hmm you called there
didn't you I just got here
Hey well you were busy living in the
past it just named a shot JFK please
hey Samantha
sorry about earlier it's a quick
questions
yeah do you have any cold coca-cola
you